selon l'organisation des nations unies
pour l'alimentation et l'agriculture la
fao
la diversité des plantes cultivées a
diminué de 75 % au 20e siècle
pour contrer cette diminution ou tout
simplement par curiosité
plusieurs maraîchers font revivre des
plantes potagères d'autrefois et vous
allez le voir les fleurs ornementales
ancestrale revient elle aussi à la mode
[Musique]
pendant des décennies nos ancêtres ont
cultivé des et pierre laineuse du modem
noire des alchimies le vol des rentes
des prix les achille et des équipes
assez puis certaines de ces plantes sont
tombés dans l'oubli
mais ces végétaux du passé font un
retour en force dans les jardins il ya
un engouement de plus en plus il ya de
plus en plus de grainetier de
pépiniéristes qui se spécialise dans
certaines semences au plan patrimonial
donc on les retrouve un peu plus sur le
marché s'il vient traboulsi dirige la
collection des plantes vivaces ou jardin
botanique de montréal depuis des années
elle consacre une partie de ses
plates-bandes aux plantes censées strahl
ce regain d'intérêt s'explique de
plusieurs façons
c'est comme un besoin de préserver les
traces du passé et de renouer avec le
passé de préserver le patrimoine
ils veulent aussi perpétuer les
traditions
de la culture de ces plantes qui ont été
oubliés donc oui il ramène tout ça ils
veulent recréer un jardin aux allures
d'époque en préservant cette tradition
et en préservant ce patrimoine là on
contribue aussi à la biodiversité au
début de la colonie les colons de la
nouvelle france cultive est
principalement des plantes médicinales
et potagères dans leur jardin
le gic in assez d'eschyle idoine de
l'absinthe
il faut attendre plusieurs années avant
de voir apparaître un intérêt pour les
plantes horticoles la fin du genre 27e
début xviiie
lorsque le régime anglais s'est établie
et lorsque des des commerçants des
riches commerçants sont venus ici en
portant leur bagage de connaissances et
aussi cette capacité de se promener un
peu partout dans le monde
donc on a vraiment eu cette cette
arrivée de nouvelles plantes
mélangez avec nos planches qui était
déjà très belle et qui était ancestrales
ces nouveaux végétaux ou proviennent
d'aussi loin que de la chine de
l'amérique du sud ou encore d'europe les
plus ancestrales sont des plantes
indigènes ou importés qui sont cultivés
jusqu'en 1945 un tournant en agriculture
c'est la fin à peu près de là de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
donc le début de l'ère de la culture
moderne donc le début de l'hybridation à
l'échelle commerciale
à partir de l'après guerre l'hybridation
s'intensifie l'hybridation est un
croisement entre deux variétés d'une
même espèce
il peut se faire naturellement ou en
laboratoire
le processus est simple on enlève
d'abord les étamines l'organe mâle de la
fleur qui contiennent pollen puis on
applique le pollen sur le pistil
l'organe femelle de la plante d'où
fécondation résultat on a multiplié les
couloirs on a multiplié les grabar on a
multiplié les formes on standardise les
plantes on uniformise leurs auteurs on
les développe en fonction des critères
comme leur résistance ou transports
l'hybridation permet d'offrir une grande
variété de cultivars aux consommateurs
les plantes change book ou dans certains
cas veuillez d'inde
vieux garçon franchement rigoler en
anglais elle l'aurait son origine vient
du mexique puis on a et trouver des
écrits depuis 1789 au québec de la
plante d'origine ne ressemblait pas à ça
donc elle était probablement d'une fleur
simple qu'une couleur jaune ou rouge
puis tranquillement avec l'hybridation
ben ils font des fleurs plus grosse des
fleurs doubles des fleurs de teinte
rouge orange jaune
[Musique]
l'hybridation favorise certains critères
ou détriment d'autres un exemple la
chine est à l'origine ces fleurs étaient
roses
aujourd'hui certaines sont jaunes dans
certains cas on perd le pare-feu de
certaines fleurs pour favoriser la
multiplication des couleurs la grosseur
de la fleur parfois les nouveaux
cultivars contiennent moins de nectar
pour nourrir les pollinisateurs
les plantes indigènes qu'on retrouve à
l'état naturel sont à pollinisation
libre c'est à dire que leurs fleurs sont
pollinisées naturellement par les
insectes ou par le vent
ces plantes lola si on récolte les
semences
on peut les recevait on peut les
entretenir
on peut les sélectionner des sauvegardes
et les récolter et les transmettent de
génération en génération
même si elles sont pollinisées
naturellement il peut exister de légères
différences au niveau génétique avec le
plan mer ces différents sont parfois à
peine visible certaines plantes empêche
l'auto pollinisation et si le pollen de
l'appelant tombe sur le pistil la graine
qui germe va mourir le pollen doit donc
provenir d'une autre plante de la même
espèce celle là c'est une hybridation
ces sombres héros adobe et orange
donc quand vous voyez c'est une couleur
orange assez à l'ars et les kin acea
purpurea à l'origine est un petit peu
plus haute
et elle est grosse donc ils font des
hybridations pour faire des couleurs
différentes le caractère n'est pas très
fixes et donc au bout de quelques années
un risque de change et puis redevenir
hop avec le temps certains cultivars
ancien ont été abandonnés pour des
raisons d'esthétisme ce qui représente
une perte pour la biodiversité
mais sur ce point sylvia traboulsi se
veut rassurante mais je suis sûr que
quelque part il ya qu'un collectionneur
qu'il l'a mais vu que ce n'est pas
encore très industrialisée et riz
commercialisé on ne le sait pas mais à
un moment donné je suis sûr qu'on va
retrouver toutes ces plantes perdu
[Musique]